[Music]
around 66 million years ago
an asteroid struck our planet and
triggered a mass extinction that wiped
out all non-avian dinosaurs
but what if it hadn't what would our
world look like
if the dinosaur dinosaurs still ruled
over it this theoretical timeline is the
subject of the speculative zoology book
the new dinosaurs written by dougal
dixon
who popularized speculative zoology with
the trilogy which also includes
after man and man after man that
chronicles evolution in the far
future dixon's work influenced other
series you might know
like the future is wild and cm cozman's
ambitious
all tomorrows but the new dinosaurs is
unique in how it imagines not the future
but an alternative form of the present
so
for this entry into the archive we're
going to catalogue this other world
dixon conceptualized
bearing in mind some of the science is a
bit outdated
and it's of course impossible to know
exactly what such a timeline would look
like
think of this book and by extension this
video
as just an interesting guess so let's
jump in
and imagine the great asteroid was just
another flash of light in the sky
and over the next several million years
the dawn rose on a new order of
dinosaurs
beginning in the continent we know as
africa humans have of course
never evolved instead the first new
dinosaurs we meet
are the strange forest-dwelling
treehoppers
and the long-faced wasp eaters the wasp
beater is similar to our timeline's
anteater
as both species spend time in the trees
and feature
lengthy snouts for reaching into insect
nests
dixon classifies these species as
arbosaurus
and his concept of a tree-dwelling
dinosaur actually came true to an extent
after this book's publication
paleontologists discovered the existence
of
microraptors small pre-dwelling
dinosaurs not far off from what dixon
imagined
moving from the forest to the savannah
we've got the hilariously
named flarp bipedal scavengers descended
from the aerial pterosaurs
like the emu or ostrich we know their
wings are now vestigial
so they're stuck on the ground even more
stuck on the ground
is the lank massive unusual grazers also
descended from pterosaurs
this species is a pretty clear analog to
the giraffe and some paleontologists
have noted it's not the most realistic
endpoint for a species like a pterosaur
but the link are just so funny looking i
can't help but approve of dixon's
creation
and in the desert the last african
species i want to touch on awaits
beneath the sand is the wyrm a super
alarming looking organism dixon imagines
this tube of a creature moves like a
snake
and can burrow under the sands to catch
prey frankly i
wonder if our snakes would be offended
by the comparison
heading north to the continent we know
as europe is a species even further away
from traditional dinosaurs
this is the gestalt a species similar in
size to ground squirrels
but dixon imagines they could build
complex nests
and even form intricate communities
these intelligent dinosaurs are
descended from pachyocephalosaurus
thick gold lizards not really known for
their brains so
it's an incredible transformation
heading to the south we have the
diminutive swim
not a dinosaur at all but a mammal the
species is close to a modern mouse and
is about as big as mammals get in this
alternate reality
this is because mammals were only able
to diversify
into the species we know today because
the dinosaurs declined
which never happened in this alternative
timeline to the north we have the hefty
tromble
similar in statue to ostriches the
tromble is a true bird
a classification which is pretty sparse
in this alternate reality
like the mammals true birds had too much
competition to flourish like they do
today
across the ocean to the region we call
north america
we've got the truly insane looking
sprint asaurus
the surreal dinosaurs are evolved from
the duck-filled dinosaurs of the
cretaceous period
with elaborate crests used for group
identification the sprintosauruses are
similar to the prong-horned antelope and
they can run at high speeds to avoid
predators
and have become fully quadrupedal
meaning they walk on four legs
the sprintosauruses are hunted in turn
by the rather deranged looking northclaw
a theropod with a single massive claw
for hunting prey
but there's one dinosaur species on the
grassland the north claw can't take down
that being the massive herbivorous
monocorn
these huge grazing animals share the
large defensive horns of rhinos but move
across the north american prairies and
great herds like buffalo
descended from the triceratops they're
maintaining their ancestors niche as
large
defensive herbivores heading to the
rainforests of what we call south
america
we've got the scale covered pangaloon a
species with an armored defense similar
to our timeline's pangolins
who for the record are just the best
nearby the massive lumberers continue
the treetop grazing habits of their
sauropod ancestors
although they now feature a trunk much
like our reality's tapers
which both species use to aid in
consuming vegetation
tragically the lumbers are preyed upon
by the fearsome
cutlass tooth a dinosaur whose unique
dental arrangement
resembles our timeline smilodon given
their frightening nature you'd expect
the cutlass tooth to be a t-rex's
descendant
but nope the tyrannosaurus rex evolved
into the rather stumpy looking gourmond
a species which lacks any front limbs at
all i mean hey
in our timeline the tyrannosaurus's
closest living relative
is the chicken so it could be worse
crossing oceans once again to what we
now know as asia we've got the mountain
dwelling tatty
the species covered in insulating
pseudo-feathers with a rather
unfortunate face
the teddy is filling a similar niche to
our reality's macaw a species
of monkeys which thrive in similar
regions the taddy's coloring and tree
swinging abilities also make it similar
to the gibbon
although unlike either monkey species
the taddy is imagined to be not
particularly smart
another species that will haunt my
nightmares the tree worms are an
elongated organism related to the desert
worm discussed in the africa section
and like the desert variety the tree
worm is a snake-like predator
and like many modern snakes possesses
the ability to climb
trees and move along branches in search
of prey pretty
unsettling stuff in a distant valley a
less unsettling but truly unique species
lurks
this is the numbskull a bipedal animal
with a swollen looking head which
almost seems humanoid in its appearance
the idea of dinosaurs eventually
evolving into a species with human-like
intelligence seems fascinating
and has been the subject of numerous
other sci-fi books
as interesting as this seems in theory
it's hard to say how likely it is a
creature with human-like intellect would
ever emerge from dinosaurs
and dixon doesn't seem too convinced
this is why the numbskull living up to
its name
isn't actually too bright further south
we come to australia
a region with plenty of unique animals
in our timeline
and dixon's vision of the place is even
crazier
this is the cribum an algae chomping
species similar in build and coloring to
flamingos
unlike our realities flamingos however
the cribbin can't actually take flight
one species that can at least get some
air through hopping is the guana
the last surviving relation to
aguanodons which hop across the grassy
plains
as you can imagine these dinosaurs have
found a similar role to that of
kangaroos and are even at a similar size
much smaller is the crack beak another
species with an appearance i find deeply
unsettling for reasons i can't quite
explain
but nature is about function not form
and the crackbeat
are quite skilled at cracking open nuts
although the species also eats insects
much like a modern australian kookaburra
and the final australian dinosaur of
note is the cloon
a strangely endearing bipedal herbivore
with a thick woolly coat
although not feeling the same niche the
animal almost reminds me of the capybara
which has a similar face and peaceful
nature
so that might be all seven continents
covered but we're not done with our list
quite yet
we still need to explore what sorts of
species are lurking in this world's
oceans
beginning near the poles we have the
aquatic plunger
a streamlined black and white organism
that's pretty clearly an analog to the
penguin
like most penguins they're described as
adept swimmers with wings modified for
hydrodynamic movement
a pretty creative idea for a species if
a familiar one
four or less familiar however is the
kraken
an aptly named species with a shell that
almost resembles a tiny floating island
the kraken has 12 tentacles with deadly
stingers and will eat anything that
becomes entangled in its traps
as you can imagine the kraken is not a
dinosaur but something that resembles
our timeline's nautilus
although our analog to this species
though interesting isn't nearly as
fantastical
and the last species we're touching on
is by far the largest
this is the walk a huge leviathan which
is a descendant of the ichthyosaur
that evolved to eat plankton this
massive species is of course
directly comparable to our world's
whales sharing similar feeding habits
and
gargantuan proportions what a creative
species
and that's the end of dougal dixon's the
new dinosaurs
like i said in the opening the new
dinosaurs might be highly speculative
but it's certainly interesting
if you ever get the chance to check out
more of his work i'd recommend it in the
meantime thanks for watching
if you like this entry into the archive
please lend your support
and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious
see you in the next video
you